hey folks please enjoyy this clip from
our show which you can find every single
day at 400 p.m. Eastern exclusively on
Rumble we've been doing the best shows
we've ever done completely free of
censorship and on a platform that
actually supports us you can also
support us on locals where you can
access a ton of exclusive content movie
riffs as well as an archive of over a
thousand full episodes going back as far
as 7 years we've also teamed up with
merch engine to bring you a new lineup
of really awesome quality shirts hoodies
and now even hats so come check out our
untethered uncensored show on Rumble
every single weekday at 400 p.m.
Eastern you stupid
idiots all right check out Bas Shack
ready dragging your feet she don't want
to hear no complaint the day you come
home and think you could be like I was
down I lost she like she going to be
stroke your ego but she going to
remember that time you you canot let
them see you one time down the world
can't see your head down one time ever
so I I'd tell you I want you both to
know that they you can no like and I I
know that you've exper no canot sorry
man I'm rejecting all that jewishness
right now okay so this is right here no
but I you don't think you've ever had
someone that you really could trust and
really open up now if you want to keep
enough if you want to give somebody El
some coochie all the time I'm saying I'm
saying if you want if you want a bad I'm
just I'm just I'm just being I guess
open up to a woman yeah never no never
what okay
pasted never known man when's the last
time you think you've opened up to a
woman we
don't you want to know why here's why I
open the last time I opened up to a
[__] was the last time I ate [__]
which is never you open up to a woman
cuz they tell you you know you're never
telling your feelings and then you tell
them your feelings and you're like all
right there you go that's my feelings
and then they go oh my God I didn't know
that and then the next time you were in
a fight they use it as ammunition
against you
yes or or you tell them something that
you're feeling that has to do with them
and then they still talk to you for a
month right yeah you're not allow you so
you really don't want to know what I'm
saying feeling or you tell them what
you're feeling it has nothing to do with
them and they make it about themselves
and then they never talk to you for a
month right right right right right
that's what a bartender is for
yeah or a podcast yeah whole life bro
I'm telling you got play like like I I
could me and him relate it are
sues yes there's some connection here oh
no and they going to tell you you can't
because you know why but it's a trap
because you know why I'm trapped like a
[__] no I'm I'm going to tell
you why cuz once you do whenever
something go down they going to throw it
back in your face that's hey there you
go you got it yep you know yep yep yep
yep yep uh also just something you
realize he has to get custom sunglasses
made right okay okay so you're not
you're very you're noticing something a
little diff yes it's about it size what
I'm about bring
up it makes it you don't really realize
how big he is but if you look at he's
using the same microphone we're using
well yeah anytime you have an item there
for scale and and you're like I know
this is not a tin these are tiny mics no
they're not small at all and they look
like remember when Andrew the giant the
picture of Hing the beer that's what it
looks like to him back in your face
that's I've had a short microphone looks
like a lapel mic on him real that's why
and look at how his legs go up and then
back down like Jesus dude you know what
I mean like he's enormous yeah his legs
look like the graph of the crypto
Market why you crack got niagar
legs oh my God even business though like
that rule even go for business like you
stay up your contracts get coming so
it's just a universal
law stay up and stop do you have
anything that you say to yourself in the
mirror or is it I know you have like a
blessings book anything to just when
you're in the words of Shaq the dword
depression is there anything that you
have to get you back on even if it's
like the worst day
ever who is this I don't know who this
guy is by the way interviewing him so
then uh of course because this is the
whole point of Shaq's thing was that
women will use something you say and
throw it back in your face and then of
course did these women throw it back in
his face The View on his latest podcast
NBA legend Shaquille O'Neal gave why do
it hurt to say that I don't understand
why you're
wincing well because remember she owned
the she was a m she coached to Knicks
and she couldn't get him that was a
movie though I don't think so you think
they going to shut down Madison Square
Garden for whoopy Goldberg the film a
movies sorry how's How's she supposed to
coach for the Knicks when she's busy
solving police crimes with a dinosaur
cop get that movie was so bad she was
wearing a nun uniform [__] C oh yeah
God damn it I was about to say the same
[__] hang the hang out with Harvey
kitel if I remember correctly she's so
busy yeah this podcast NBA legend
Shaquille O'Neal gave his advice on
communicating in a
relationship oh Jay-Z's trying to look
like whoopy Goldberg that makes sense oh
okay makes sense yeah sorry take a look
think you've ever had someone that you
really could trust really open up open
up to a woman yeah never no never I'm
going to tell you what cuz once you
do whenever something go down they're
going to throw it back in your face
that's I've had real and then every guy
knows that is a truth but then every but
then you but but what you're but then
what you yeah what you're doing yeah
what you're choosing to do it's almost
like when somebody gets called the nword
and then they tear up an entire [__]
Airport terminal and beat beat up four
people and three cops way to prove me
right yeah you know what I mean you go
well you know I get you're mad but it's
not
helping a well what is he doing and what
is he
saying they they w women have this in
their DNA I I swear to [__] Christ
where they do not see how ironic they're
being it blows my mind it really blows
my mind what was he
saying that has been used against him
because I think open communication is
very important in a relationship and
I'm what show is that was that Family
Guy or American Dad that had the View
Family Guy Family Guy and one of them
just lays an egg been up if you know
that was such an elegant joke because
it's like yeah I'm not even writing a
joke about you it's just what this is my
husband up if he you know if he's has is
struggling with something but if Shaq is
telling a
womanle with 10 people I'm sorry I slept
with them she IM look by the way Shaq
wasn't even implying he was cheating on
her no but that's where she goes cuz
she's been cheated on a list every woman
on The View has been cheated on a
lot and I've cheated on you and maybe it
does get thrown back in the face I I
just think it's ridiculous maybe he
deserves it maybe he's a piece of [__]
maybe that's the reason we don't tell
you anything maybe he shouldn't have
told me he wasn't going to come with me
to his wedding and then he broke it off
like 2 days beforehand and she starts
getting very specific oh my God I think
there directed at somebody else I think
Partners need to speak to each other
they need to communicate and and what
better communicators are there than
women I men men sorry sorry men would be
my first choice men are the better
communicators who's who's who's better
at communicating other than a bunch of
dudes can I be honest men I'll also go
dogs I'll go cats uhhuh uhhuh Dophin
Dolphins elephants
parrots parrots pars a lot let me tell
youis yeah I am way more fascinated by
an African gray parrot than I am any
woman I don't know I'll get I had an ex
who would say that every time I got
hysterical I'd get historical which was
like you know every twice a day
sometimes three every time I got
hysterical I got historical and bring
out all sorts of things from the right
so you're proving a point yeah yeah you
guys with a parrot and every time they
go to the bathroom you immediately start
trying to teach it terrible oh yeah
every Paradigm try I try at least at
least got a lesson in the nword
mhm memory I do think um I do think that
there might be a little bit of a
cultural thing going on here because
like with me personally it's like I come
home if there's one dish in the sink
I'll bring up your old divorce what
Jesus because like for Latino men you
know when a Latino baby is born they
hold it up and they say oh it's a boy
and then the second thing that comes out
of their mouth
is men don't cry men don't emote men
hold it in I suspect there's something
going on similar yeah men don't cry and
men don't emote because Hispanic women
if you do that in front of them they
[__] blood in the water and you're
not a [__] man anymore see women
always say what men men don't do things
CU they in a vacuum okay we do things
because we look at the consequences of
is it really worth it to bring it up the
black when gay guys it's like when that
gay guy's aita dog saw him getting
bottomed and then wouldn't look him in
the eyes anymore yes much less do you
emote or complain or whine I've dated a
lot of black men and I really I don't I
don't
know I think hold on hold on see who dat
more black guys hold on black men and
and I I don't I don't know
Sarah's like
same I think Sarah and I can agree
you're not
wrong sorry football players love me we
know Sarah we could tell you're the
archetype that said I think that anyone
that did yall know
that what does it matter know she [__]
black guy what is the m what does it
matter oh cuz we got to cheer that kind
of stuff on cuz we gotta you know dilute
your you know well you're blushing honey
look they were good
relation L yeah CU everybody knows why
she dates them by the way women this
entire segment is why we don't tell you
[__] this segment you're watching then
you throw your misation in our faces
yeah and I ain't going to [__] have
we don't stand for that around these
parts we don't stand for that around
these parts
okay it's 1864 in this house
uhhuh she's okay go go read something
it's called Mississippi Burning all
right that's the law of this house if
you're you if you're using very close
intimate details a toxic
[Laughter]
relationship you cannot weaponize things
you've learned in periods of
vulnerability it's like the number one
it's the number one sorry I can't move I
have nothing to add yeah no hey at least
you're honest sweet hey you know
what good come on give her credit hey
you know what out of all [__] on The
View I've ever heard in my life you're
at least the most self-aware one I have
nothing to add will be still wearing
Crocs I
don't
nothing sorry girl I like the one on the
right was like look I don't [__] black
guys I don't really I'm not I'm out of
this one I'm tapping out yeah Memory
Lane girl the only thing I would say to
this is you might want to make sure that
you're talking about specific people as
opposed to saying women because see you
guys can be pretty much atomized down to
a
molecule make sure you're talking about
specific women no no no no no because
we've we've watched a lot of these clips
of the [__] view over the years okay
and I hear men men all men men men men
all the time out of you guys and you
don't talk about don't talk about
individualism when you [__] paint a
wide bro white people white people in
general are all the same right out there
who are great communicators who are
shrinks who are helping lots of men get
through the you know shrink is like even
when you use the word shrink it's it's
actually
an psychiatrists don't call like to be
called shrinks it's an offensive word
right they're shrinking your brain yeah
it's like [__] yeah exactly it's the s
word [__] so I actually called my
therapist the [__] and they're not even
Chinese that's true that Jewish lady got
very upset at me yeah